the three steps
know yourself accept yourself and become
the creator
first taught by ra in
the law of one and further popularized
by bentino massaro
and i have found
this to be so direct
the most direct
in spiritual awakening
there is nothing as precise
and as simple as this
so i'm really excited for this
three step to become
more and more popular as the direct
path
so first is knowing yourself
and it can be easily thought of
as analyzing your
frames of life and behavior patterns
but like a scientist with no bias
things like where you go what you do
how you use your phone time
money and so
similarly to these
30 or 60 frames per second
motion pictures
movies films video games we're gonna
treat
our lives similarly where we see
these frames
and to keep it simple we can do one per
second
and let's say that in one of the seconds
there's a specific thought that's coming
up and then in the next frame
is showing up a different thought
and so what we're doing is we're
becoming aware
what is showing up in that frame
now what's showing up in the next frame
because if you become aware that you
had a thought that was
angry or depressed
you can further create a distinction for
yourself
on how to be not
angry or not depressed but instead
be happy be peaceful
so this is really important is being a
scientist with no bias
as you analyze your frames because it's
very easy
to have a series of frames
that you're not very
proud of and because of that sort of
manipulating what happened
and kind of lying to yourself
and so it's really important to be like
a scientist with no bias in this process
and so as you analyze your behavior
patterns especially where you go
what you do how you use your phone time
money if you look at your calendar
and you're doing things
that are
trying to extract
peace and happiness from reality
that i will be happy when i attend this
concert or when i go to this club with
friends
and get drunk
that now you're becoming more aware of
what am i putting in my calendar
how am i spending my time how am i
spending my money
richard condon does a really good job at
saying that
if you look at where
you allocate your primary resources of
your checkbook so your wallet so your
money
and also your schedule so your time
if you look at those two places you can
understand
what you've committed your life to what
you're orienting your entire life around
and so it's going to be really important
for you to embody
more and more of this non-biased
scientist
approach to your frames of life
to see honestly what am i aligning my
life towards
am i aligning my life towards going out
on the weekends
am i aligning my life towards reading
books
am i aligning my life towards becoming
closer friends with people that can
actually
mentor me and teach me and help me
become more wise
how are you using your phone if you look
at a period of time
that you're using your phone
how are you using it are you using it
for
trying to seek validation and worthiness
by making posts that then
you hope that people will look at you
and like
your post and you'll bring you
validation
are you using your phone
to study are you using it as an
educational
technology are you using it to
communicate with other people that
you're creating
empowering technologies
with
so this first one is all about knowing
yourself it's all about analyzing your
frames of life understanding your
behavior patterns
and then creating these distinctions
so as you learn what your life is
aligned to
you're tapping into this question of who
am i and why am i here
more and more so you're unfreezing your
will
your will has been frozen and so you're
running
these scripts and you're not aware of
your frames of life and your behavior
patterns
so now what you're doing is you're
unfreezing your will by
asking yourself who am i why am i here
what is my life aligned to let me
analyze my frames of my movie
and let me begin creating distinctions
for myself
if i'm experiencing suffering or anger
or depression or trying to seek peace
and happiness externally
how can i create a distinction in my
frames to not
be suffering or angry or depressed but
rather peaceful or joyful
how can i not spend my time
and money on going out trying to get
validation and worthiness
and peace and happiness but how can i be
peace and happiness how can i be 100
worthy
and free and valid off the bat
and growth happens in chaos
meaning that
being stagnant or static
with these frames is going to perpetuate
the same
scripts that have been going on so only
by truly scientifically analyzing the
behavior pattern
and then going like nope i'm not going
to be angry or i'm not going to be
depressed
i'm going to be peaceful and joyful now
creating a distinction and then turning
and rearranging your life through chaos
to this growth of peace and joy
is how to actually be able to
unfreeze your will know yourself more
deeply
and then realign your life to something
that is
more whole more divine
more peace and joy more you more
truly you and the hawthorne effect is a
very
important way of looking at this and
the general idea there is that
if you're being watched you're more
likely to change your behavior
so for example if
while you've looked at this frame of
life and behavior pattern you've created
a difference between you
suffering and you being joyful and now
it comes up again where it's a big chain
of depressive
suffering thinking now if there's
somebody also present
in the room with you that
is watching you
and that you've told them that
hey i'm gonna catch myself in these
chains of depressive thought
and i'm going to
take a breath and relax away the tension
of those
depressive thoughts that now you're more
likely
to be holding yourself accountable
because there's another
observer there's another witness
watching you
and so you have to train yourself with
this hawthorne effect
so that you hold yourself accountable
if you've made a declaration
about knowing yourself about switching
from suffering to peace and joy
you treat it like a true declaration
and you work yourself
to changing your state of being away
from the suffering and towards the peace
and joy
and if this requires you to have a
friend
nearby that you trust
to be an accountability partner and
you're an accountability partner for
them
then do it do what is needed for you to
more
scientifically non-biasedly
analyze your frames of life and your
behavioral patterns
so that you can unfreeze your will and
become more sovereign
in making any state changes to your
being
that move you towards becoming the
creator and shift you away from being
just a contracted
person
so that covers knowing yourself and
accepting yourself is about dissolving
subconscious lack beliefs of
unworthiness
of seeking validation by radical
acceptance of those subconscious lack
beliefs
and that enables the shift from person
to becoming the creator to the very god
son
that's always already whole and free
so mark heinen has a really good program
called accept yourself
that walks people through this process
identifying what is the core lack belief
that we've picked up and put into our
subconscious at a young
age that we now are
unconsciously living
into life through all of our behavior
patterns and actions
so if you look back when you were five
years old when you were 10 years old
something may have happened to you
almost certainly
that contracted your identity
it made you feel like you weren't worthy
it made you feel like you weren't
already loved that you weren't already
free
that you weren't already valid
but that you had to go and seek
worthiness and you had to seek
validation and you had to seek money and
fame and clout in material possessions
and only a spouse could make you happy
only having kids could make you happy
only a big position at a company could
make you happy
only a house in the suburbs could make
you happy
and so we picked this up in our youth
whether
through our family or through society at
large creating these subconscious lack
beliefs
and so through accepting ourself what we
do is we
radically accept that when we were 5 or
10 years old or 15 years old
and when we picked up this lack of
belief of i am unworthy
that what we're doing is we're radically
loving and accepting the fact that when
we were
15 that we picked that up
because what happens is when you
lovingly accept
the fact that you picked up that lack
belief
you're shining the light of awareness on
it whereas if you don't
look at it if you don't shine the light
of awareness at it it's gonna
perpetually
run your life subconsciously
but if you do shine the light of
awareness on it
what will happen is the subconscious
lack belief
will be loved and accepted radically and
completely
and it will dissolve and you will
transcend that lower frequency
chess game it's like you're playing
chess this is a great analogy
popularized by bentino massaro
you're playing chess against
these corlac beliefs and instead of
playing chess
against i am
unworthy with that feeling trying to
extract worthiness
from manifestation from creation when
you tip
over the king and surrender and admit
defeat
to that lower frequency subconscious
lack belief that
we've been carrying for years or decades
it enables you to
shift from that personhood to
the god state to this very god
son to this very always already
whole and full state of love
and completeness and we begin to radiate
that out
and so this is another core pillar
along with knowing yourself is accepting
yourself so you're going to know these
frames of
life and you're becoming more and more
vigilant with your behavior patterns
and you're becoming more aware of any
subconscious lack
beliefs and you're transcending those
through love and acceptance so that you
can merge
more and more with the kingdom of god
that is the radiant sunlight that has
been present the whole time but that has
been obfuscated by a cloudy perception
and that's what enables this last pillar
of becoming the creator
a full recognition of union with the god
son with infinity
seeing oneness and unity everywhere
radiating pure service pure
shepherding energy
and so you'll really clearly see the
distinction
right it's really important in our
frames of life to continue
seeing the distinction of am i still
coming from my subconscious lack belief
or am i coming from the state of already
being whole
of the god realized state of
sunlight radiance of pure service and
shepherding energy
and so over time what we do is we become
more
and more aligned with coming from the
god state
and less and less of coming from the
core lack belief
subconscious conditioned person state
and so that's more and more of the full
union
with god the full union with infinity
with oneness
and so that's when you deepen your
relationship
with the decentralization of your
identity
because there is individuation but
there's no separation
and so it's important to remember as you
decentralize your identity from all of
this subconscious conditioning
and you merge more and more with the
universe you merge more and more with
life itself as your identity
you recognize more and more your truest
essence is
absolute infinity and that the universe
is
a manifestation of possibility
in that it is but one
infinite creator endlessly expressing
itself
and that you're giving the entire
universe
your love like the sunlight
and you're giving it all of your energy
as
pure service pure shepherding energy
of awakening the creation to its true
nature
as the one infinite creator
and so these are the steps
this is the most direct
process
to unite with the most awakened
energy of recognizing yourself as the
creator
the shift is from being a victim
to being the creator it's shifting from
being a person
to being god it's the shift from
separation
to unity and oneness
and the shift is most
simple through these three steps
of knowing yourself accepting yourself
becoming the creator
knowing your frames of life knowing your
behavioral patterns
creating these distinctions so that you
can truly
see who am i why am i here what am i
aligning my life to
and how can i experience more peace and
joy and more actualization
and less suffering
and accepting all of these subconscious
lack beliefs that we've picked up giving
them the love
and acceptance that then enables
them to dissolve and for us to transcend
them to this god
state the always already
whole
state of pure love
pure service pure shepherding
pure infinity pure oneness pure unity
and that's the most direct path
and so i'm really excited about how
this most direct path will land in your
hearts
so do let me know where you're at in the
process in the comments below i'd love
to hear from you
if the video brought you value give it a
like subscribe to the channel
share the video with other people that
you know this would profoundly impact
read the law of one also bentino
massaro's
content is fantastic you can watch a lot
of the global enlightenment retreat or
the mirror talks podcast
which are very popular on this channel
also the no limits society is a great
organization that's focused around this
as well
that i'm a part of and have been
learning and growing so much with
mark haynen's program called accept
yourself is fantastic that i've been
through
and that i would highly recommend you
guys to go through as well
to really radically love and accept
those core subconscious lack beliefs
that then enable you to shift
to the god state to infinity
to oneness
and those links are all in the bio below
as well
i'm pumped for this to become more
popular the three steps
know yourself accept yourself become the
creator
and ignite global awakening baby from a
place of pure service
non-attached shepherding
because you know your truest nature
and you've surrendered the chess game
of being a person with subconscious
core lack beliefs and you've
become more vigilant with analyzing your
frames of life and your behavioral
patterns and you feel so much more
sovereign so much more empowered
you feel so much more of the shift from
person to god from separation to unity
from
victim to creator
from infinity to infinity
you feel more united with the true
nature of reality
thank you infinite love
you